okay so take a breath that was question
four now question five is where we
really struggled and admittedly part of
this
was quite likely to do with time and so
all those comments i made earlier and
they continue through this part as well
about choosing the most efficient method
are really really relevant because
sometimes
you absolutely know how to do these
questions but having chosen an
inefficient path
you just completely drastically run out
of time so we're not just it's not so
much about assessing speed
it's about assessing your ability to
choose method and when you choose an
inefficient method that's
why you struggle so having a look at
this
question here if i go back to the go
back to the question paper
you can see what i've done that's the
wrong document let's try this one
that one shouldn't do and let's see here
i've got that over on the
left hand side let's actually move away
and put on the right hand side
there we go okay so question five here
we are solve the equation
and you can see i've just rewritten it
ever so subtly differently
right um you've just got all those terms
there and i've gathered them
so that you can see here i've got this
is my um
you know i've got an a coefficient
leading coefficient one
i've got a b coefficient of minus 2 plus
3 i
and then i've got a c coefficient of 1
plus 13i
and i've done that so that this line
here which i know you might not
recognize but this is just the quadratic
formula without a big awkward square
root sign
or a big awkward division sign so that i
can put it into
minus b plus or minus the square root of
b squared minus 4c on 2a just
rolls off the tongue and you get to this
point here this is me expanding what's
underneath the square root
so you get this you're gonna have to
collect like terms which gives you this
and it was actually just low-key really
heartbreaking how many students
um got to this point but they had done
something wrong in the collection of
like terms so it was actually
like you seven and eight algebra that
tripped you up on this question
especially at an early stage if you got
something
drastically different under here or even
like closely different
you wouldn't have something which gives
you nice neat square roots
of the discriminants so then you ended
up giving up because i don't know what
the square roots are i can't find them
so for those of you who did get to this
point and it was fine my
negative 9 minus 40i you can find the
square roots without too much difficulty
by
creating this pair of simultaneous
equations here summing one into the
other and you get two solutions
and once you've got those you can take
them back into the
quadratic formula which is which is here
i'm going to write plus or minus and
then i'm going to put in the square root
of the discriminant
right here so that brings me to this
point here so there's uh
this is my minus b plus or minus this is
the square root of
b squared minus 4ac it's just i had to
do it all in complex numbers
divided by 2a so collecting like terms
for my two separate solutions my
negative and my positive case
this is what you get they both divide
through by two and so these
are the solutions of the original
equation so that was part a
all right now part b before we dive into
it um
this is another question where and it's
not the only one
you live or die based on the diagram
right so that's part of why
in part b part one um you know the
question prescribes
plot this right put this onto an argand
diagram
the cube roots of unity should be some
fairly easy things to draw
and it was really disconcerting how many
of you didn't know where the cube roots
of unity were
or you had a very small diagram it was
very difficult to use and so several
students actually didn't even attempt
this second part
the geometric reasoning to show that the
area of that triangle which you get
equals
this so that's a question for young
players now there are many different
ways to solve this suite of problems
particularly part one
so let's just remember what the question
is we're going to plot
the three cube roots of unity and then
we're going to try and find the area
of the triangle enclosed by the cube
roots of unity and i've given you the
result here just so you could use it if
you wanted to
so how do we do it well i'm going to
show you three different methods here's
the first one
you can see my diagram down over here
and what i've decided to do is say well
i can break this
uh triangle abc the big triangle i can
break it into
three smaller triangles that are
congruent to one another so you can see
let me shade this one in here
like so so if you can work out the area
of one of these triangles
and you can see that in the working i've
done it via the um the sine rule
or the sine rule for the area of a
triangle i should say once you've got
that if you can show
through geometric reasoning as the
question prescribed that the other two
triangles are identical in area then you
can just triple it
now one of the problems was even though
the question clearly stated and i'll go
back to it just to be clear
it says use geometric reasoning to show
that the area is given as such
several students sort of skipped out a
lot of this very important logic that
showed
i know what the you know the lengths of
these triangles are and that's
that's how i show that they're going to
have equal sides i can work out these
angles based on my diagram so therefore
i've got
two sides and an included angle so again
some students i'm skipped over that
working which is really important
and then once you've got these congruent
figures you can say the areas are all
equal
because flipping over a shape or
rotating it as long as it is congruent
that means it's the same
dimensions and the same proportions and
everything so therefore
they have equal areas and that's where i
got to
3 over 2 comes from the front here and
then root 3 on 2 comes from this
sine of 2 pi and three that's how i get
the required area
now it's not the only way um you could
have used the sine rule not just on a
smaller like a subtriangle you could
have done it on the whole thing
and if that was what you wanted to do
the easiest way was to instead of as i
did up here
instead of writing your complex numbers
a b and c in exponential form
several of you and this was fine for
working out this question
you wrote your a b and c in rectangular
form so
the reason why that's helpful is because
it allows you to work out some key
lengths like bc
in terms of um you know just using your
rectangular coordinates and you can see
in my working here
that's exactly what i've done see from
the vertical coordinates you've got bc
being the positive root 3 on 2 and then
the the negative root three on two but
i'm just interested in the the magnitude
not in which direction so that's why you
get
those two added to each other which is
root three uh
better answers like because you went
down this path you really kind of had to
show
that you had um these angles in uh
triangle abc now the reason why that's
trickier is because triangle abc
this bigger triangle here isn't directly
related to these
sides in here you've actually got to do
some work there so that's why you can
see me here
doing all of the angles on the triangle
adding adjacent angles because you need
to work out this angle plus this one
you get there via this being isosceles
so you can work out their pi on 6
independently so part c x plus 6 gives
you pi on 3.
um i suppose you also could have made an
argument from showing that this is
equilateral but that would have been a
fair bit of work as well
so anyway once you get the angles in the
big triangle being
pi on 3 you also need to be really
careful because
you then use that a b equals bc to get
the other side if you're using the
area of a triangle using the you know
half
a b side c that kind of thing you need
to have two different sides here
and you can't just use vertical
coordinates to find out these two sides
because they're diagonal
sides so therefore you can only use that
vertical coordinates trick for this side
um you've got to do something else to
deal with these other two sides you can
see what i did
was showing that i've got equal angles
opposite equal sides which is true for
equal lateral triangles as well as it's
true for isolate these triangles
so that was the second method uh and
then the last distinct method that i saw
is that you can work out the vertical
coordinates and the horizontal
coordinates to get
bc which is this length here you can use
your vertical coordinates for that
and then you can use your horizontal
coordinates to work out this which is
the perpendicular height
if you call bc the base of the triangle
and the reason why that's nice
is because then you can just do half
times base times height
which is what i got down here but you
just need to be careful because
um unless you say something like this
you've got no reason to show that that
one's the base and one's the height like
you need to justify that
so that's why i showed that bc is a
vertical interval
so ad is on the real axis so you've got
a horizontal
versus a vertical that's why they're
perpendicular so that was the third
method
okay now we had to keep on going so part
two there are a couple of different ways
to do this
again the simplest way by far and if you
just want to remember what the question
is let's um pull it over and open over
here
we needed to prove that if omega is one
of the complex values of alpha so it's
one of the complex
cube roots of unity we need to prove
that omega squared plus omega equals
negative one
how do we do this well like i said the
most simple way is to say
omega cubed has to equal 1 because it's
a cube root of unity
so therefore you can subtract 1 from
both sides to get
this polynomial here and then you can
factorize this polynomial here to get
this particular pair of
products now a big caution is that a lot
of students
arrived at this line or for that matter
even this line and that was their first
line of working
that does not fly like this is a prove
question so you've got to show
where this where this comes from right
and in addition to that even the
students who did start
um from this line rather than the next
one which is you know you could even
just get that from the question you
don't need to understand anything to
write this
even though students who did write this
line they didn't exclude the fact that
you know if you've got two numbers right
if i say to you hey
a b equals zero does that guarantee
that b equals zero and the answer is
no it does not because b could be
anything as long as a is zero right the
only
way you know b is zero is if a
can't also be zero right so therefore i
know in this context
here's my a and here's my b as it were a
lot of students
rushed to say a times b equals zero
therefore b
must be zero but that's not the case
right five times zero is still zero and
that second number there or actually
zero times five equals zero
b can be five and it can still uh you
know equal zero so therefore
you had to make this statement right
that you know omega
is is not a real number it's complex so
therefore omega can't equal one
which means that this cannot be a
solution so this would be equivalent to
saying well i've got a b
equals zero and i already know a can't
be zero because the only way to make a
zero is over omega
is real and we've already excluded that
so you have to be very careful with your
logic here and a lot of students
really fell down and didn't know where
to begin and where to go so once you've
got that you can identify
this factor must be the one that gives
you solutions then you subtract one
you're good to go
there was another way to go about it and
several students tried this even though
i think it's quite easy to argue this is
a longer and more
more error-prone and confusing way to go
about it you could have said well let's
let's do roots and coefficients of a
polynomial okay
i'm going to name each of these roots
because i call them alpha the beginning
of the question
i'll call them alpha 1 alpha 2 and alpha
3. so
therefore i say this is the polynomial
equation i'm dealing with
the relationships between roots and
coefficients means i can say the sum of
the roots is equal to minus b
on a and minus b is the co or b rather
is the coefficient of omega squared
there is no omega squared so therefore b
equals zero and a
is just going to be one which is that
coefficient there so
that's why you can see down here i get
negative 0 over 1.
but you're getting a set itself because
a lot of students jumped very quickly to
saying
well the 3 roots must be 1 omega and
omega squared
i'll grant that one of the roots has to
be w and one of the roots has to be
omega
because i told you that in the question
but i have not provided the question
that omega squared
is one of the solutions you have to show
that yourself and so that's what this
working in here
is all about a lot of students
completely skipped over this
and using this this method they didn't
show that omega squared had to also be a
root because it doesn't have to be
so therefore this is the kind of working
that needs to be shown you didn't have
to do an exponential form any form would
do
but once you've got that you can then
say all right here's my three roots
one omega omega squared they equal zero
just like we saw before
and so you subtract one from both sides
and you're good
okay now we then the task was for part
three we need to use that result right
we wanted to use
the fact that omega plus omega squared
is equal to negative one now
several students didn't use this result
at all right i did say hence or
otherwise so you can do
other stuff but you just if you multiply
this set of brackets by this set of
brackets you get nine terms
it's just long it's error prone it's not
an effective way to go about it again
this cost you time which you needed
later in the paper
so this is the best way to do it you can
see what i've done is i've factorized
out the the first
omega plus omega squared i could see
there's two omegas here and there's also
two omega squares in here there's just
an extra line left over
so you can see i've factorized them out
in the middle 2
times negative 1 is negative 2. so if
you want to think of it this way
this becomes this one
and this
becomes this one and then you have to
continue through here
you end up with this pair of um terms
here which need to be expanded
but this is much more modest than having
these trinomials multiplied by one
another so this is okay i'm happy to
expand that
you find another omega squared plus
omega and you also have i've kind of
like skirted past this you've also got
an omega cubed
but by definition because omega is a
cube root of unity
omega cubed must be one and so that's
how i deal with that
um so you've got this one and this one
they give you two
and you're subtracting negative one
that's three as required